Traducteur: Michele Gianella
Relecteur: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
La question est la suivante :
nous sommes dans un pays où il y a
700 milliards de dépenses sociales.
Certains disent 15% du PIB mondial.
Et pourtant, rapport après rapport,
la pauvreté ne fait qu'augmenter
et nous croisons tous les jours,
de plus en plus,
dans la rue, dans le métro,
des gens qui ont une pancarte
avec marqué « J'ai faim ».
Donc ma question est très simple :
mais où est passé tout cet argent ?
Vous avez ici la courbe exponentielle
de dépenses des prestations sociales,
et à côté quelqu'un qui a la bonne idée
de ne pas nous emmerder avec son accordéon
mais qui a besoin d'argent pour survivre.
Alors, où est passé l'argent ?
Il est passé dans les rouages
d'une machine bureaucratique
extrêmement complexe,
construite avec beaucoup
de bonnes intentions,
décennie après décennie,
et qui superpose différents
dispositifs d'allocations.
Et comme toujours
avec ces machines complexes,
vous avez des « insiders »
qui la connaissent très bien
et qui en profitent largement.
Et vous avez des « outsiders »
qui sont laissés totalement à l'écart.
Pour vous donner une idée,
pour gérer aujourd'hui
les 90 milliards de prestations de base,
il faut 18 000 règles de droit.
Les minima sociaux en France,
aujourd'hui, c'est ça.
Et encore, c'est la petite partie
émergée de l'iceberg.
Donc, la question plus fondamentale,
plus philosophique en un sens,
c'est : pourquoi a-t-on construit ça ?
On a construit ça
parce que ce système d'aides
est basé sur l'identité des gens :
il faut définir qui ils sont,
quels sont leurs besoins,
quelles sont leurs aspirations,
quelle est leur vie de couple.
Et qui dit identité dit vérification,
qui dit vérification dit contrôle,
qui dit contrôle dit injustice.
Aujourd'hui, pour percevoir
le minimum du minimum, le RSA,
qui est d'environ,
pour le RSA socle, 500 euros,
vous devez aller passer
des entretiens aux CAF.
Les CAF, ce sont les caisses
d'allocations familiales.
Quel rapport ?
Ça vous dit tout
sur l'étendue du paternalisme
qui régit notre système social.
Aujourd'hui, quand vous demandez le RSA,
vous devez remplir
un formulaire de dix pages,
ce qui fait qu'entre un tiers et deux
tiers de ses allocataires potentiels
ne le demandent pas.
Vous devez passer des entretiens
qui peuvent être particulièrement
humiliants, discriminants.
Vous êtes étiqueté comme pauvre.
Puis, ensuite on peut vous en donner trop,
alors il y a des procès pour indus du RSA.
Comme les sommes diffèrent,
si vous êtes en famille,
si le RSA est familialisé,
on peut vous demander
d'en rendre une partie,
on peut même aller contrôler
que vous êtes bien en couple.
Il y a quand même des attendus
de procès pour indus du RSA,
où on va vérifier
si oui ou non il y a deux brosses
à dents dans le même verre,
ce qui voudrait dire que les personnes
ne sont pas colocataires,
mais véritablement en couple.
Bref, c'est un système intrusif.
Et ce que nous vivons tous en proie
avec la bureaucratie tous les jours,
les personnes en difficulté le vivent
d'autant plus et d'autant plus mal.
Alors comme toujours,
quand il y a un problème de société,
les poètes, les poètes
de l'époque, s'en emparent.
En l'occurrence, récemment,
Virginie Despentes et Ken Loach.
Dans son dernier roman,
Vernon Subutex, premier volume,
Virginie Despentes décrit
la longue descente aux enfers
de la victime parfaite de notre temps :
Vernon Subutex, disquaire,
ruiné par l'irruption du numérique,
n'ayant pas droit
à un certain nombre de prestations
parce que c'était un indépendant,
un entrepreneur,
qui se retrouve finalement au RSA
et qui perd un jour le RSA
parce qu'au hasard d'une conversation
avec sa conseillère CAF,
il a laissé échapper que oui,
il lui arrivait d'aller voir
un concert avec cet argent,
et que donc non,
il n'était pas forcément
en recherche d'emploi.
Aujourd'hui, pour percevoir le RSA,
il y a un certain nombre
de conditionnalités.
Si vous ne les remplissez pas, vous pouvez
en être exclu, ce qui arrive à Vernon.
J'ajoute que si vous reprenez un emploi
et que vous êtes chauffeur Uber
pendant deux mois,
vous perdez le bénéfice du RSA
qu'il faudra aller requémander.
L'autre est Ken Loach.
Vient de sortir sur les écrans français
son film « Moi, Daniel Blake »,
qui dans un autre contexte,
et dans un autre pays,
décrit à peu près la même chose.
Il était Palme d'Or à Cannes
l'année dernière
et je vous propose d'en voir un extrait.
« Je n'ai pas le choix. »
« Vous avez le choix,
mais vous allez me coller une sanction. »
« Je suis le règlement. »
« Si vous devenez agressive,
je vais vous demander de partir. »
« Je suis pas agressive. »
« J'explique la situation
mais ça vous est égal. »
« Pourquoi ce boulot ? »
« Sécurité ! »
« Je vous transmets au décisionnaire. »
« Je veux plus vous entendre.
C'est toujours pareil ! »
« Je suis désolé mais vous devez partir. »
« D'accord, lâchez-moi.
Je veux parler au responsable. »
« J'essaye juste de lui expliquer. »
« Je lui explique. »
« Je ne vous parle pas.
Retournez là-bas. »
« Parlez-moi, si vous avez
quelque chose à dire. »
« Je lui expliquais qu'on est
jamais venus à Newcastle.
On débarque à peine de Londres.
Je sais pas me repérer.
J'ai pris le mauvais bus.
On a couru pour pas être trop en retard.
Elle veut rien savoir.
Et elle va me coller une sanction. »
« Ce que vous allez faire,
c'est m'écouter.
La dame a raison.
Il y a des règles, on doit les respecter.
Ce n'est pas contre vous. »
A part le fait qu'ils aient
l'accent de Newcastle,
c'est un film très parlant
et qui vous montre à quel point
les gens sont traités comme des enfants.
Alors, la solution qui peut être proposée
pour remédier à ces phénomènes,
c'est le revenu universel.
Pour le définir de manière
extrêmement simple,
il s'agit de donner
à chaque personne majeure,
de 18 ans à sa mort,
une somme d'argent
qui lui permettent de survivre,
sans conditions, sans contrôles
et sans aucune contrepartie.
Cette somme est déterminée
comme la somme qui vous permet de survivre
dignement dans une société donnée,
et est attribuée
à chaque membre de la société.
Alors, vous demanderez peut-être
sur quels fondements philosophiques
on peut défendre une idée aussi baroque.
Il y en a beaucoup.
Je vous en propose deux,
parce que ce sont deux personnages
de la même époque,
qui ont tous les deux participé
à la Révolution française.
Le premier, l'échevelé à gauche,
c'est Gracchus Babeuf, l'égalitariste,
celui qui voulait non seulement un revenu
minimum, mais aussi un revenu maximum
et que de préférence, ils coïncident.
C'est la version
qui existe encore aujourd'hui,
la version collectiviste,
la version socialiste du revenu de base.
Et puis vous avez à droite Thomas Paine,
vous voyez qu'il a l'air
nettement plus sympathique.
Thomas Paine est, disons, un libéral,
mais il a un parcours très intéressant :
c'est un Britannique,
intéressé par la Déclaration
des Droits de l'Homme en France,
ayant répondu à Burke, qui la critiquait,
émigré aux États-Unis où il a participé
à la révolution américaine,
dont il est parfois considéré
comme un des pères fondateurs,
et ensuite réfugié en France
où cette fois il va participer
à la Révolution française,
au point d'être le premier étranger
naturalisé français,
élu à l'assemblée nationale en 1792.
Thomas Paine conceptualise,
dans « La justice agraire »,
les linéaments d'un revenu universel
tel qu'on l'entend aujourd'hui.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que sa double culture
anglo-saxonne et française
fait qu'il cherche à réconcilier
Rousseau et Locke.
De Rousseau, il retient l'idée
qu'au début, dans l'état de nature,
régnait une certaine égalité
entre les hommes,
égalité vis-à-vis
des ressources naturelles,
et que nous avons cet héritage en partage.
Et que les inégalités
de ce point de vue-là
sont une forme d'injustice,
par rapport à cette égalité primordiale.
Mais de Locke, il retient l'idée
que l'enrichissement,
la transformation de la nature en valeur,
la valorisation des produits,
la possibilité de créer,
de s'attacher des biens par la propriété,
est tout à fait louable
et permet les progrès de la civilisation.
Et c'est donc pour réconcilier les deux
qu'il propose son revenu universel
en disant : « Nous allons vous compenser
pour la perte de votre héritage naturel. »
Et comme cet héritage
est le même pour tous,
cette somme sera la même pour tous.
Il a une phrase qui je trouve
résume très bien sa philosophie :
« Je me fiche que certains
deviennent très riches
du moment que personne
ne devient pauvre en conséquence. »
De sorte que ce revenu
ne sera plus considéré comme une charité,
mais comme un droit qui, dit-il,
viendra compléter la Déclaration
des Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen.
Alors, vous êtes en droit de me dire,
aujourd'hui, c'est un peu utopique.
D'abord j'aimerais préciser
que je déteste les utopies.
Je vous recommande de lire d'ailleurs
la première du genre,
l'Utopia de Thomas Moore,
qui est un véritable enfer
où la longueur des rues
est déterminée par l'État
et où les activités de chacun
sont contrôlées à l'heure près.
Une utopie, c'est toujours
le fantasme de quelqu'un,
imposé au reste de la société.
Le revenu universel n'est pas une utopie,
d'abord parce qu'il ne résout pas,
il ne propose pas de plans d'ensemble,
ne propose pas des visions de la société,
il ne propose pas de valeurs communes.
C'est tout le contraire :
il donne à chacun la possibilité,
en lui donnant son minimum d'autonomie,
de déterminer ses propres choix de vie,
de déterminer sa propre
définition de la vie bonne.
En un sens, la société,
avec le revenu universel,
atteint un tel point de sophistication
qu'elle donne la possibilité
à ses membres de s'en soustraire ;
et deuxièmement, ce n'est pas une utopie
parce qu'aujourd'hui
en France, il est très réaliste.
Et je vais rentrer un peu
dans le détail des chiffres.
Il est très réaliste
parce que nous avons accumulé
tellement de prestations,
nous avons un système
tellement redistributif,
que passer au revenu universel,
ça serait changer les tuyaux
mais ça ne serait pas changer
la masse des transferts financiers.
Ça ne provoquerait aucun bouleversement
économique dans le pays,
ça changerait seulement marginalement
l'argent que les gens perçoivent,
ou qu'ils payent sous forme d'impôts.
C'est très bien expliqué
par Lionel Stoléru,
qui est l'avocat du revenu universel
depuis les années 70,
qu'il avait importé des États-Unis
où Friedman l'avait remis au goût du jour,
et si vous parlez à Stoléru,
il vous dira que la longue série
des grandes réformes sociales -
RMI, TPE, RSA, prime d'activité -
va dans le sens du revenu universel,
qui est l'aboutissement logique
de cette série.
Donc les conditions sont là.
A quoi ressemblerait-il ?
Nous avons travaillé avec des économistes
qui ont modélisé tout cela,
et donc je vais passer
très rapidement sur le détail
pour vous donner la conclusion :
la conclusion, c'est que vous
pourriez avoir à coût constant
un revenu universel
qui est une sorte de super RSA.
Encore une fois, c'est pas la lune,
ça ne résout pas tous les problèmes.
Mais si vous faites
un revenu universel de 500 euros,
l'équivalent du RSA aujourd'hui,
en mettant le logement de côté,
donc un revenu universel qui couvre
les besoins de consommation courante,
consommation, nourriture, logement,
énergie, télécommunications, transport,
vous l'évaluez à 500 euros.
Vous devez le financer par un impôt
qui se substitue à l'impôt sur le revenu
de 25 % sur l'ensemble des revenus,
ce n'est pas rien tout de même.
Vous avez un schéma
où, en fait, ces 500 euros,
attribués donc à chaque
individu, chaque mois,
prennent la forme d'un crédit d'impôt
et puis vous avez pour compenser,
pour financer ce système,
pour qu'il soit à l'équilibre,
cet impôt sur le revenu à 25%.
Et chacun fait la différence
à la fin du mois
entre l'impôt qu'il doit, les 25 %,
et le crédit d'impôt
qui lui est dû, les 500 euros ;
de sorte que si vous touchez zéro,
eh bien vous touchez
les 500 euros en cash ;
et là vous êtes libre de les utiliser
de la manière que vous voulez
sans rendre de comptes
et sans avoir à les demander
en sachant que c'est un droit
dont chacun bénéficie.
Si vous devez un million d'impôts,
vous n'en devrez plus que 999 500.
Et tous les cas intermédiaires
sont possibles,
donc si vous touchez,
par exemple 1 000 euros,
eh bien, vous devrez payer 250 d'impôts,
et vous aurez votre crédit d'impôt de 500,
et donc vous toucherez
au final 250 en plus.
Donc c'est un système
dans lequel, comme toujours,
il y en a qui payent,
il y en a qui reçoivent,
mais simplement, c'est fait
sur une base beaucoup plus équitable.
D'où la question suivante, bien légitime :
pourquoi madame [Bettencourt]
devrait-elle toucher le revenu universel ?
Je dirais d'abord,
c'est ce qui lui permettra de survivre
quand sa fille lui aura tout piqué.
(Rires)
Mais blague à part,
vous voyez bien que le revenu universel,
étant quelque chose
que vous voyez chaque mois
sur votre feuille de revenus,
ou même d'ailleurs sur vos impôts,
même si vous n'en
bénéficiez pas directement
parce que le montant des impôts
est bien au-delà du montant
du crédit d'impôt,
c'est quelque chose
qui reste avec vous toute votre vie.
De sorte que l'angoisse
de la grande pauvreté disparaît.
Et souvent, quand j'expose ce système,
j'ai des réactions de personnes
au RSA qui me disent :
« Pour moi, votre système
ne changerait pas grand-chose,
économiquement parlant,
mais ça changerait tout dans ma vie
parce que je cesserais d'être
un quémandeur professionnel,
j'aurais une stabilité et une visibilité
sur l'argent que je reçois
et je pourrais faire quelque chose
de plus intéressant que d'aller aux CAF. »
C'est donc un système
extrêmement vertueux
parce que, d'abord, il élimine
de manière automatique et radicale
la grande pauvreté :
plus jamais vous ne verrez quelqu'un,
résident légal sur le territoire,
avec un panneau « J'ai faim ».
Impossible.
Deuxièmement, il simplifie
de manière extrêmement égalitaire
et simple, transparente,
le système d'allocations d'un côté
et des impôts de l'autre.
Troisièmement, il permet
que le travail paye toujours,
puisque dans un tel système,
dès que vous gagnez plus,
vos allocations diminuent
de 75% par euro gagné.
Enfin, il permet que tout le monde
paye l'impôt, fût-ce virtuellement :
chacun reçoit mais chacun contribue.
J'ajouterai qu'il est particulièrement
bien adapté à un monde dit post-salarial,
où les gens peuvent exercer
une pluralité d'activités différentes
et donc dont les revenus
sont discontinus de mois en mois.
C'est un filet de sécurité qui s'ajuste
de manière immédiate, en temps réel,
à la disparité des revenus des individus.
Vous remarquerez qu'il y a des choses
dont je ne vous ai pas parlé.
Je ne vous ai pas parlé
de la fin du travail,
de la robotisation,
des communs collaboratifs, etc.
Certains technophiles fondent
l'argument du revenu universel
sur l'idée que nous allons tirer
une rente sur les robots.
Tout ça, c'est bien joli,
mais on n'a pas besoin de cette réflexion
pour passer au revenu universel
parce que le revenu universel,
ça peut être ici et maintenant,
en France, en 2017.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)